samedi eh ben j'ai fait ma deuxième dose
du coup balaji d'ici une semaine le pass
and i ter sera obligatoire pour les
jeunes sportifs de 12 à 17 ans du voisin
football club pour l'institution qui
compte entre 700 et 800 licenciés au
total l'organisation a dû se faire en
amont nous on a commencé à réfléchir à
ça sur quatre soit un jour d'août pour
toute cette organisation là on l'a testé
sur les premiers matches de coupe de
france avec les seniors le seul petit
problématique reste sur les quatorze qui
sont les plus jeunes ou le certificat de
vaccination est pas encore présent parce
qu'ils sont en cours de vaccination donc
il reste encore tout ce qui est est pcr
enfin à d'autres cas pour pouvoir jouer
au foot sans forcément se faire vacciner
déjà appliquée pour les adultes et donc
bientôt pour les jeunes le pass c'est
l'espoir d'une saison qu'ils puissent se
jouer dans son intégralité contrairement
à l'année passée c'était dur parce
qu'elle ne voulait faire des matches
comme comme avant lui mais qui avait le
cou raide bah c'est pas du combat oui tu
es en étant peu dégoûté avec toutes les
règles qu'on devait respecter pour les
entraînements de l'année dernière au
bout d'un moment il y avait une
lassitude des joueurs donc là ouais ya
beaucoup de photos ils ont plus
l'habitude d'aller au contact une
reprise qui réjouit tout le monde bien
qu'une problématiques persistent en vue
du 30 septembre 5 à 10 % de l'effectif
total du club n'est pas encore vaccinés
j'ai fait le point ce week-end au niveau
de l'équipe une il y en a deux qui sont
en train d'attendre leur deuxième dose
et vous faire leur deuxième dose de la
semaine prochaine pour le premier match
officiel il va falloir qu'ils fassent un
test et il y en a un qui ne veut pas se
faire vacciner donc pour l'instant
ce sera un test à chaque fois avant les
matches le club de voisins a choisi de
mettre en place une commission de santé
avec des professionnels du secteur pour
préparer la future organisation de ses
joueurs non vaccinés à l'étude
l'hypothèse de payer les tests pour les
matchs aux joueurs concernés
[Musique]